welcome
everyone to yet another topic on junit
now in this one we are going to talk
about what exactly is in junit uh
tool all about and how we can do various
kind of
test implementations with the help of
junit now in this one specifically we
are going to talk about like
some tutorials or some demos on how to
implement
junit with eclipse now let's talk about
what exactly is the junit tool
all about like what are the different
things we can implement with the help of
this tool here
so junit is basically a kind of unit
testing framework which is there for the
java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the junit
for the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing
now the main benefit of the junit is
like
it's using the same syntax like a java
programming language
so it makes it very easy for a java
developer to write and execute the test
cases
so most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages
so they prefer that j unit as a default
unit testing framework for them because
they get the language advantage they get
the easily
integrations and the eclipse so those
benefits helps the developers to decide
junit
specifically for writing the test cases
and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code
so uh all the unit test cases will be
executed will be again executed there
every time when you run a new belt so
all the unit test cases gets executed
but you also need to take care that if
you are adding up a new functionalities
you also have to add the corresponding
test cases to that
so increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time
you have to sync or you have to keep
your test cases up to date also
and as a part of every build each and
every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times
six times a day every time the all unit
test cases will be executed over there
and the response will be given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing
now unit testing refers to the testing
of these small small modules or the
small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to
have the early identification of the
defects and the bugs because
you cannot simply rely on the qa team to
perform the testing
and then provide the feedback whereas on
the uh with the help of this unit
testing framework we can
immediately get the feedback right away
once we are
running the test cases we immediately we
will be able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have
got over here now the developers don't
even have to spend
more time on fixing the bugs and issues
because these test cases will help them
with the easy and the fast feedback
so according to that they can fix the
bugs and they can take the decision
whether the
source code is working fine as expected
or there is any kind of issues
as such present with this one so unit
test casing is something which is very
important from the developer's
perspective also
because it helps the developers to
understand that they whether they have
written a successful code
or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh increases the overall
confidence of the developers
because it uh increases the overall
performance and the quality of the
product also
so by having the successful executions
of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take
uh the decisions whether the source code
is ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit
which we get with the unit testing here
now of course this can be done in two
ways manual testing and automatic
testing
now in case of manual testing you have
to do this thing manually
within a manual tester or a manual
testing approach
and in this one you will not be
depending on any kind of automated tool
which can be scheduled or which can be
executed in non-interactive manner
on the other hand automatic test case is
something which
is used to be executed using the tool
and uh it is something which is being
done so that you will be able to get
the complete automation there is no
manual efforts which is required as such
you are going to have like complete uh
deployment and automations being done as
such in this case
so automated testing is something in
which you will be giving more focus
on the automated automation tools you
may be having one or a couple of tools
which
using which you can write the automated
test cases and you can perform the
complete
automation in case of manual testing
it's quite uh
you know less reliable because you are
dependent on the uh a particular
tester which can ha perform the testing
according to his efforts and it's quite
a time consuming
also because you can only run the test
cases for probably eight to nine
hours per a day whereas on the other
hand the automated test case is
something which is
quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so
so requirements so it can be done like
24 crore seven so anytime you can run
those
uh test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster as
compared to
any other manual testing approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases really helps the
developers and the qa professionals to
test the source code much faster
as compared to the manual testing now
the next one which we got over here is
the changing test cases using the
eclipse because from the command line we
saw like using the comma line we can do
but we got like so many test cases which
is available there so it's not easy for
us to run those one by one
so we will be doing it through the
eclipse so that we can see like how the
execution can be really done
and we can get a hold of those
particular components so let's go back
to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here
now let's create a new project again
here
j unit
project right and finish
so a new j project a junit project will
be created
now in this one you can see like there
is no executables libraries for junit
but you can include it now also but i'm
going to do it later on so i go for the
j unit project class
right so this is a kind of a test class
here so i'm not going to put the
null the public void mean over here in
this one so
finish now in this case what i'm going
to do is like i'm going to
you know replace this content over here
so uh with this uh particular ones
and uh going to have some basic core
base added up over here
so i'm going to import some particular
junit
uh libraries over here so over here like
oj.j unit i'm going to import these ones
and i got like this
class over here junit uh you know
project so i just have to rename it a
little bit so that it can be the
name of the actual class uh name here so
that's fine
so everything is fine but the only thing
is that we are getting some failures and
problems over here because it's not able
to identify these
specific junit related executables like
the functions and the methods
for this one again the previous like
previous case you have to do the
uh particular addition of the library to
the build path
so that you will be able to have like
these automatically resolved over here
in this one
right so you can see now that the unit 4
started reflecting over here in this
case and you did not got any kind of
errors now over here in this one so you
can simply save this
and now you can you are good to go for
running the executions over here
so you can simply say like right click
over here
run s and change unit test and when you
do that
on the left hand side you will be able
to get a little bit different viewpoint
over here
which says like yes test and score j
unit is something which is executed
perfectly fine
if for any reason let's say like i
change the value of
string one here as in string one just an
typo error i'm trying to do here so that
i can show you that how the test cases
really fails
so assert equals is basically helping to
find out that if
the comparison between the two
attributes is correct
that means that uh you know the inputs
which we are putting up and whatever the
output we are getting
it's both the same here when you do that
you will say like there is a
failure over here to the test cases now
i'm seeing the
failure trace over here so i'll just
move this one to the console view
so it says like it should be like string
but i got like string one over here
which is causing the problem here
because of the typo error which i did
the whole execution of the test cases
got failed
so i'm just going to revert my changes
back here and again from the test cases
it will all be okay right now again over
here so that's a main reason that how
the execution really happens in the
overall
mechanism and the system can be
implemented over here in this case
so that's how we basically go on and we
execute some
junit test cases here so this is the
basic uh demos which we did about the
junit and how exactly it
goes for the implementation of the unit
test cases here
so that's it for this topic thanks
everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here